this is Jacob bonanda and Oscar
ingvalson Educators guides and Resident
Vikings from the Viking Museum in
Stockholm Sweden today they're joining
us to check out some of the world
weaponry and mythology of God of War
Ragnarok one detail that I caught on
owner's model is that the eye patch
Arrangement has some extra straps yeah
and one of them has a what we call this
a disc that has the roon f on it what's
the name of the F room uh you you can
help me there you've got to do your
homework yes big thanks to all at the
Viking museum for joining us on this
episode you can see more of them in our
God of War 2018 episode but either way
make sure to go and check them out all
of their links will be in the
description below but without further
Ado it's over to the Vikings
[Music]
first of all and last time we talked
about this and watched the the other the
first game he had a teaser of someone
who visiting Kratos with a tool in his
belt
tool
at last we get to see who it is but it
was four obviously the first impression
of Thor is someone
uh almost a biker type and we can also
recognize or by his red hair red beard
so and I like that image I am grateful
it didn't go the blonde version we're
seeing a lot of well popular movies
let's put it like that
laughs
okay let's start by talking about the
tool of Thor his hammer again they've
gone with the you know post Viking age
runes slash symbols
I I don't like it that's no secret but
at least it's consisted with the
Leviathan ax you can also see a design
of the hammer head is you can recognize
that it's mjolnir the hammer or Thor so
it's not just in the imagination of the
creators is also based on at least some
images from the Viking age or based on
image of Viking age I would say and then
it starts to fight and he use mjolnir as
the suspected too actually I I would
have expect him to use lots more you
know active but most of the fight he
spends with his hands but then again we
see this at the end he's trying to go
the Kratos into unleashing the what we
call it the ghost of Sparta yeah the
Destroyer aspect which Thor's apparently
quite bitter about to be in Norse
mythology as we'll see later yeah now uh
one dramatic thing when you you're
supposed to die in the game spoiler
alert it's been out for quite some time
and if you're out watching this video
it's already too late but Kratos dies
you go to the game over screen and then
suddenly electricity what's going on
well he used it as a Thor is using it as
a defibrator to make Kratos live again
and that's very funny to use that he can
put off offline lives but also put on
lives again with his heart starter don't
try this at home kids
I mean look at that
well I absolutely love this part because
I've never seen uh these walls being
portrayed in any way and it's the
protective wall of Asgard built by a
giant and his horse and it's also
interesting because Luke has a big part
in this story when they were building
this wall when Oscar is building the
need a protection wall and one of the
Giants are suggesting he is the one who
could build the wall to the gods but he
wants to marry the freyja as payment and
the gods wants the wall but wants but
Freya do not want to marry this guy so
Luca comes up with well let's make it a
time limit if he can do it on the winter
and you will have Freya and then they
will know that it's not possible to make
the wall just for winter so they will
have a half wall and Freya can be back
at home but this man rimters this um
giant has a horse and the horse are very
efficient in this way of working so the
wall is building up very fast and they
see he will manage to make the wall in
the time he has so therefore Luke needs
to come up with a plan so he turns
himself to a beautiful horse as you do
and he starts to be very attractive in
the horse way he seduces the stallion
yes so the stallion will run away into
the forest and leave the poor giant by
himself and the wall will not be ready
in the winter time also the Guardian
guardian of the wall later uh
in the mythology and he is a very
important figure in protecting Oscar and
also the whole world in some kind and we
meet him for the first time in this clip
too and hanged all are famous for many
things but also because his hearing and
his sight now one detail that I find
quite neat is the portrayal of Handel in
a white tunic because in the sources
he's known as or the White House the
white God this way Loki of the yognar
wait is that gjallarhorn are you hindall
in my opinion the galarhorn needs it
needs a little work
there's plenty of amazing archaeological
finds of horns either as it's shown in
the game it's a horn from a some kind of
animal they have edges which is trimmed
in copper alloy and bronze or tin silver
sometimes but from Denmark from the 5th
Century A.D or so you find the the
galenos horns which are worse on gold
unfortunately in the 19th century they
were stolen and melted down but detailed
drawings of the motifs on it were done
by Danish archaeologists fortunately and
they are quite spectacular Hymnal sword
it looks off the proportions are way off
the handle it's too long and the pommel
appears to be a little too small the
cross card however it's at least
recognizably Viking age it could be a
what we call a Peterson type D it's
popular in hallway in the 9th century I
gotta give props for the Scarborough it
looks pretty good inspired by
illuminative manuscripts also the quick
detail of the Scabbard shape the thing
at the end of Scarborough that we see
looks very good in fact Rocky
you made it I am so honored I I see
you've met Heimdall we see Odin in this
game and he he's depicted in a unusual
way usually when you see me has got this
long flowing white hair
yeah this game is bald but you can still
recognize this Odin of for some ways in
some ways for example he has these
Ravens all uh Raven details all over his
body or uh outfits outfits one detail
that I caught an owner's model is that
the eye patch Arrangement has some extra
straps yeah and one of them has a what
we call this a disc looks like silver it
has the roon f on it what does the F
roon mean in what's the name of the
afroof uh you you can help me there you
gotta do your homework yes no it's fear
it's literally in his castle but it
means wealth or power almost and it's
interesting that it's wearing the symbol
of wealth on its head which sort of
conveys the way that he values knowledge
above all things and we see this in
Norse mythology as well he's obsessed by
knowledge he's a knowledge Seeker he
sacrifices well his eye as well but also
he sacrifices himself to the tree ah the
Box good those are for him I understand
you're an avid reader these are just a
few things from my Personal Collection
uh thanks one little I also light is
when Lucas invited into the lodge he is
giving a large pile of books and books
are perhaps a symbol of knowledge but
perhaps not associated with Vikings and
the Scandinavians if you will written
something down with runes or to know to
knowledge to teach during working-ish it
would probably not be in this pile of
books but presumably you'd use bone horn
or wood uh Stone the scene would have
been very funny if Odin had done the
large pile of you know runestones yeah
ruining inscriptions or stone tablets in
his well Embrace rather than these books
Seth you missed welcoming our new house
guest say hello to Loki
this is him
here we also meet another God in Odin's
Lodge Steve the wife of Thor you can
also see that she looks strong and
perhaps has a strong personality and I
guess you need that if you're a wife to
Thor as well as you can see the she's
got enormous amounts of golden hair and
she's famous for her amazing looks in
Norse mythology she's also a little bit
hostile to Loki yes and because Luke is
a big part of why Steve has this golden
hair in the sagas or hematology and
lucky Cuts saves hair and a surprise yes
as a prank and then needs to get new
hair to sieve otherwise he will be
killed by Thor and so he seeks someone
who can make new hair for for Steve and
finds this find it in the dwarves so the
dwarves makes the the golden hair to
thieve and literally gold this time yes
and in the game you can see it's
glimmering like gold so perhaps this has
happened before whoa Loki right gotta
say the irony of this isn't lost on me
this was his room you know his my
brothers your brother Modi so in this
game we get to see almost the full
family of Thor this is fruit she's not
mentioned many times in the history but
you can still recognize her as well as
the the first things we were talking
about
um he's described as
she's very strong her name means
straight yeah she has the red head hair
of the family of Thor and she has
similar personality I guess as Thor at
least as we know Thor so you can see she
is in the family of Thor in this August
she sometimes are mentioned as just a
strong woman but also that she is
serving the yard in walhall in Norse
drinking culture the serving of the Mead
which is a high status drink is supposed
to be done by a high such as women of
the Gathering of the party so in a
gathering like this and we have Thor I
presumably have Thor's wife save his
daughter through the serving this time
she's trying to get Thor to well stop
dreaming
yes and of course an attempt to get Thor
to stop drinking and you know
predictably in a bar fight food England
office is in ball hack with the two main
well past times are fighting and
feasting combining the two seems like
the natural thing to do very on the
brand yeah great soldiers these and
Harry are they tend to come out of
Valhalla a little foggy they ain't
hurrier I think is mentioned in the
first game as well is the Fallen
Warriors of Odin's Army if you say so
human Warriors that dice at the
battlefield and Odin picks them to be in
his army to be ready for Ragnarok day he
doesn't pick them the Valkyries the
Valkyries and they bring them to wallet
yes but this ain't Harrier in the game
is this white pale people and in this
clip we will see wooden walks around and
tells us that is important for them to
remember who they were in life and he
also mentions some names when he is
talking to some of them and these are
also historical persons or at least from
the sagas yeah a rothkar from the Bible
story for example is named and there's
some other names that I can't remember
now but they're still from different
sagas so there are heroes in the sargas
and that's a fun detail of this scene
so we get to see lingbucker he is a
special creature he's from the Icelandic
sagas I think it's from one of the
circus
exactly he's just mentioned as one or
two very important creatures of that
Saga that he is a fish or turtle-like
type of creature that
um also is an island and tries to lure
people on top of him and then he drowns
them in in the sea outside Greenland it
might be based on you know the
impressions of these huge creatures
living in the Greenland sea yeah you
know the Atlantic looking like Islands
before suddenly disappearing underwater
we have to remember that the material
that we have to reconstruct the Norse
mythology is very limited
we only have access to a fragment of the
possible stories and sagas which was
told during the Viking age and during
the Early Middle Ages yes and sea
monsters like this are very common in
all mythologies so it could also be a
mix of other mythologies stories told by
other cultures and becomes a mix of all
so but it's a cool monster I wouldn't
say monster even it's just a really big
creature in a recent game it becomes
quite emotional for the well at least
for meemer who's what does it call it
youthful mistakes
Adam trap it and give it as a gift to
Odin and this is very only brand for the
God of War sagas which pains you know
the gods and the well worst possible
lights I'd say
foreign
[Music]
and now about this beautiful ring drop
there in some sources it is a ring
sometimes it is an arm ring but mostly
or more often you see it as a ring on
your finger and it's a musical and you
can recognize all the myths about it
mentioned in this story as well that is
becoming eight more something like I
think every night is supposed to spawn
nine all right more rings but of course
Italian various the detail I like is
that when Cinder is trying to give it
away he becomes very reluctant which
plays upon the supposed greed it entails
famed from or actually the source of the
whole helmet myth the ring in this
neighborhood the German Opera from the
late 19th century one thing that's also
interesting about this story is that
they are going underwater to get it and
it's also another other story about
another ring but is also a famous ring
so they combine the two stories of the
mythology the draftner story and the
anvari story when Luke again a part of
that story is getting The Treasure of
andvaria from Ron a god from under
Waters and perhaps this mermaid-like
figure is wrong
the most impression yes and they have an
old take about and mix these stories and
make their own that this the same ring
both anvara's treasure and droughtner
and I like that combination of stories I
have I have one complaint yeah just like
the handle of mjolnir troutner
this is a spear it's probably out of
frame so we're gonna drop it like this
but this is approximately two and a half
meters long and this is the average
height of a regular spear during the
Viking age they decide head itself is
quite okay and
this is you know relatively
realistically another complaint
I am not a complaints I'm sorry is that
he uses it to hand a lot and while we do
see this depicted in some sources the
vast majority of time so it's your spare
being used is just one-handed but also
in an overhanded
fashion
like this yeah and me be you know not as
strong as Kratos I'm easily able to
handle the spare one-handed
a lot longer but you're almost as tall
as craters
seven feet
I don't know close enough
I'm not finished with it yet
well you always want to talk about the
appearance of these people I want to
talk about the people
underneath the clothes if you say so way
to make me look shallow Jacob yes yes
that's what I like to do anger Buddha is
a interesting person or a creature or a
giant or semi-giant in the mythology she
comes from the the Giants
patients lives in the forest and she
takes care of wolves as her children and
he she also gets some children with Luke
so the thing we get to see this is
perhaps when they know get to know each
other later on they will have some
beautiful children like
um the German Gander from The Immigrant
serpents the middle Serpent and
Defenders wolf and also they have a
daughter that is half rotten Hill hell
yes beautiful woman half called rotten
corpse and then of course you meet the
is it the future mother-in-law gorilla
yes and she's not from the mythology
she's more like ice Icelandic folk sagas
she is mentioned in stories Eda for
instance but she's way more famous from
Icelandic folklore and this giant lady
is also eating cats right
she eats you if you've been bad if you
don't get any clothing or any socks you
get eaten by the cat
don't go to Iceland terrible place no so
Jacob thought so far it's a very
interesting take of luki and I liked the
fact that they are combining all or at
least many stories where Loki is a key
feature in the sagas or mythology and
they have it briefly spoken of and the
characters are appearing in the game but
there have always their own take of it
almost like someone telling the story as
in Viking age you tell the story not you
will not write it down in one or Odin's
books in the game you will probably told
the sagas and then you have your own
take of it so I see this game a little
bit like a scald telling the story of
Loki in his own way yeah
I like that too actually and after we
did the first video I played through the
first game it was really good and I'm
really looking forward to play this one
as well if anyone out there has a PS5
please send it to me Orton me
thank you so much for watching Remember
to like the video If you enjoyed and
leave a comment for whatever game
Universal franchise you want to see our
experts break down next and we'll see
you in the next one